and sydney you're 14 years old
when i was 14 if you pl please at ease
i keep forgetting i'm president
[Laughter]
same here joe
[Music]
welcome back oh we got a great show
martha mccallum
is here which is amazing
[Applause]
given how bad her day went uh did she
have a tough time getting up this
morning
i did go
[Laughter]
thank god she's fine but uh her commute
to work was a disaster
oh martha martha just uber it from now
on it's
just embarrassing but you made it in so
we're happy
so do you feel like the two political
parties don't matter anymore
it seems like now the two competing
factions are a malevolent media
and the people they call racists the
media makes it clear who they don't like
and it's half the country
the half that shows their love for their
country because that means you must be a
racist
rube right mara i was really disturbed i
saw
you know dozens and dozens of pickup
trucks with
uh you know uh explicatives against joe
biden
on the back of them trump flags
and some cases just dozens of american
flags
which you know is also just disturbing
because essentially the message was
clear it was
this is my country this is not your
country
i own this explicatives
yes the new word amazing so you know who
else was disturbed by seeing dozens of
american flags
the nazis at normandy
but i digress the new york times rushed
to her defense
in a tweet saying she was irresponsibly
taken out of context her argument
was that trump and many of his
supporters have politicized the american
flag and the attacks
on her today are ill-informed and
grounded in bad
faith ill-informed and grounded in bad
faith that should be the motto for our
show
again
again how do you take something out of
context when everybody
can hear the full context her
implication of course is that patriotism
is political
only if it's expressed by someone she
doesn't like
if it were a leftist waving an american
flag it would be a different story
mainly because it would be on fire
think about mara it's divisive and
racist to not agree with her
even when she can't do the math oh you
got to remember this
you see it as a possibility if he wants
to spend a billion bucks
beating this guy he could do it
absolutely
um somebody tweeted recently that um
actually with the money he spent he
could have given every american
a million dollars got it let's put it up
on the screen
when i read it uh tonight on social
media
it kind of all became clear bloomberg
spent 500 million on ads
u.s population 327 million uh don't tell
us if you're ahead of us on the math he
could have given each american
one million dollars and have had lunch
money left over
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's an incredible way
of putting it it's true it's disturbing
it does
it does suggest you know what we're
talking about here which is there's too
much money in politics
i never get tired of that i could watch
that every day
but let's face it that was unfortunate
it's like the lady on the subway said to
me last night you shouldn't do that in
public
[Laughter]
sorry too much money in politics isn't
the problem it's not enough brains in
the media
i mean who did the math for her cat
now of course it's obvious
bloomberg's 500 million would only give
a million bucks to 500 people
not a million each to 330 million people
that would take 330 trillion bucks
when joe biden heard that number though
immediately announced a new 330 trillion
dollar stimulus plan
everyone gets a million bucks president
oprah
fact is it's no surprise the media can't
do simple arithmetic
they're so bad with numbers brian
williams still thinks he's on at 6.
so the flag is evil the pickup truck is
evil
what american symbol could be next god
forbid they go after apple pie
that's as american as a gm factory in
china
but as if on cue in the guardian
newspaper food writer
raj patel claims apple pie is racist for
the dessert is linked to a vast and
ongoing genocide of indigenous people
they literally call
anything racist as long as it's not a
newspaper
raj claims that apple pie has deep roots
in slavery and colonialism based on
stolen land wealth and labor
which kind of sounds like china right
now lebron
but also apple trees are racist too in
johnny appleseed
more like johnny crappleseed yeah
he's still got it he took the trees to
mark the frontiers of u.s expansion
which
destroyed the communities so yeah johnny
appleseed was a bad seed
but raj isn't done yet so grandma how do
you get your pie crust
so flaky oh that's an easy one honey two
parts crisco in one part slave labor
yep raj says the sugar in the crust was
courtesy of the french slave trade
better throughout those kamala cookies
[Laughter]
i'd say she's the face of colonialism
but as you can see there's no face there
that's very creepy so just like
everything else pie crust is racist
i wonder how the angry white male feels
about that
[Music]
you know what the guy makes some good
points i don't want to make anyone angry
no more apple pie for me after this
piece of course
good you know what i don't know about
this
oppression is delicious
oppression is delicious how white of him
angry blackmail anything to add
so
so she finds it disturbing that people
are out driving trucks waving the
american flag
minding their own business a couple
weeks after memorial day
well i find it disturbing that they
allow people
to talk about things that can't pass
basic math
you know what else i find disturbing
every time i go over my white friend's
house
and take a shower never have washcloths
that's disturbing
also his head's above the shower head
which is amazing
thank god for cicadas did you know that
the white house press charter plane
scheduled to leave dc last night was
delayed by the insect which had invaded
the plane's exterior sections something
about them being attracted to jim
acosta's cologne
the plane was set to leave ahead of joe
biden's first trip abroad but was held
up for seven hours
so how did they solve the problem they
called in the one person who could save
the day
using only her mouth are you ready
cheers actually i'm less scared of this
okay oh the crunch
you have a wing hanging out of my mouth
yeah brianna's in so many cicadas that
when the temperature
hits 90 she emits a loud buzz
now there's a true american hero so for
the 4th of july if you can't eat apple
pie
try the cicadas until we find out that's
racist too
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's ghost
she's dug up more dirt than cnn
employees looking for bugs to eat the
story anchor martha mccallum
he's so libertarian he just made a
campaign donation to none of the above
part of the problem podcast host dave
smith
and telemarketers hang up on her when
she answers
fox news contributor cat tim
and they gave him a group discount and
he was dining alone
my massive sidekick and host of nutsedge
on boss station
tyrus
welcome to the show martha i'm glad you
made it here in one piece thank you guys
too i mean after that morning it's
amazing in the afternoon
you might have a problem i don't know
what it is i'm not pointing any fingers
but does the sight of the american flag
fill you with fear
no i was thinking though you know like
if people put a flag at their house is
it are they saying like
i own this it's not yours like yeah kind
of
no kind of they are um you know i i
thought that's true
i think the reaction the new york times
is interesting they obviously circled
the wagons around her wouldn't you love
to be in the meeting because they
obviously have so much stress when
they're deciding
are we going to circle the wagons or
aren't we going to circle away like
barry weiss was out the door that was by
her own choice and then they you know
ditched their science professor
uh who was a great coven 19 reporter for
something that he said a few years ago
at an outing that they had already
settled between them right then when the
daily beast wrote about it they got
together again and said i'm so sorry you
have to go and like barry weiss says
twitter you know sort of runs there
runs the business ultimately so but but
she got lucky they decided they're going
to because of her math skills
yes they decided they would keep her
around no it is it just depends where
you are on the spectrum of political
ideology they will not save you if you
are
any any any further
right of left of center than your your
god so barry weiss gets to go the
scientist gets to go
she gets to stay because again she's
really good at math
um it's the media dave just going down
the america
what all the things that america is good
at and tracing them back to something
evil is that the new
the new game well at this point i don't
think there's that many things that
america is good at
so they are they've made it pretty easy
for them it is it's bizarre
i don't know what angle to take on this
one of the weird things obviously that
was stupid and
judgmental and the craziest thing is
that it's so snobbish
yeah i mean like you know they they make
the the so-called left i don't see this
as being very left-wing actually it's
very corporate
but here's a woman a professional
looking down her nose at people in what
a pickup truck
right but because she's decided she's
lefty and they're like white
supremacists or whatever she gets to say
they're the powerful
but i almost wonder why are
conservatives
still flying the flag i mean it's like
it's joe biden's government
the media hates you yeah the the the war
on terror has been focused in at right
wingers
and you rubes are still out there waving
the flag maybe you should put it down so
you're saying they should become
radicalized they should become the
radical left
that's what you're trying to say they
should want revolution at this point
well they try
some of them do but not in my family but
you know a couple of the neighbors are a
little
out there tyrus um that was a
i sympathize with you when you're taking
a shower how could you possibly
i didn't say empathize i said sympathize
i sympathize i don't it's very
uncomfortable it is
it is it's it's it's you know you just
get used to it after a while but
when i'm just i'm glad this whole racist
thing's coming out about apple pie
because
i've had some issues and i'm glad we're
bringing it up because you just can't
stop at the apple pie no i mean yes
that's the gateway
to becoming a grand wizard but we gotta
go
a little further than that let's let's
talk about water
water yeah what were the overseers
drinking while the rest of us were
working
water probably with an ice cube in it
yeah so we got ice and water
racist
damn it you know what i want to see what
it's like on the other side let me just
it's cold nobody shoot me
oh racist is good
terrible if we remove everything that's
problematic based on its history we have
nothing left
all you're going to do is each is gators
you have nothing you no not even that
if the standard for something being
problematic is that
it is descended from a time
where bad stuff happened we will all be
canceled and just have to lay around
and starve right that would be the only
thing that we can do
and she gets to stay uh they called it
racist by the way after people
mocked her for the math thing right he
said i would these racist attacks race
had nothing to do with it bad
faith attack there was no faith involved
i've seen a lot of
instagram memes that say faith is belief
in something not seen or heard
i both saw and heard what she said
exactly
there was faith of no kind yeah it it it
it's
it's i don't know um oh
yeah but it's racist not to call it if
i'm on here
and i'm my math is off and none of you
say anything to me like well he's doing
the best he can
that's the way brian williams everybody
made fun of brian williams he was the
guy that brought it up they're both
idiots together they're one giant
they're a two-headed idiot
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else